good morning everybody and welcome to
the meeting of mid-suffolk District
Council development control B my name is
councilor Kathy gustry and I'll be
chairing the meeting today
may I please read some domestic
arrangements please do not interrupt
speakers or hold separate conversations
While others are speaking if you're
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt meeting you may
be asked to leave please ensure your
mobile phones and laptops are on silent
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so I think
we're all logged in now council members
of the Publican press May record fill
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
so the introductions first of all the
area planning manager Gemma Walker legal
advisor in Dupre
case officer Daniel Cameron governance
officer Alicia Norman and we also have
Beth Webb over there and we have Claire
streaming our internet today so thank
you very much
if I introduce members of the committee
we go down the line there's councilor
Muller councilor Gould counselor custom
councilor melon councilor Norris
councilor Stringer and Council of War
boys
good morning to you all
so move on to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
to receive any Declarations of
disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests or
non-registerable interests by members
anything to declare
no thank you Declarations of lobbying
alterations of personal site visits
so we move on to the confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 23rd
of November 2022 are there any points
regarding accuracy of the minutes
you know can I have a proposal please
councilman thank you under secondary
please councilor councilor Norris thank
you
so we now go to an electronic vote on
this one please
what is that vote is now in progress
this one
I agree with that
Council of warboys
can I take your vote verbally please
yeah mine didn't work either so thank
you chess that is seven votes four and
one abstentions that is carried
thank you
I'll sign them during the meeting thank
you to receive notification of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme none received chair
thank you
will do the order in which they appear
on the paperwork and on the internet and
we'll start with DC 2203 922 Whitten
Park thurlstone Lane Whitton and Daniel
if you'd like to present the case for us
thank you very much thank you chair
this is an application for retention of
change of use of part of a care home to
HMO creating 32 new units
office
um just something for clarity before we
get into the presentation too far I've
been made aware of some correspondence
between the enforcement team and chair
of Clayton and Whitman Parish Council
sorry
they've queried the comments received
from the enforcement team with regard to
this application
um they reported on the 9th of August
that there are no live Enforcement cases
recorded against this site
um
from the emails that's incorrect because
it is an enforcement case recorded
against the site but I think for clarity
the enforcement case wouldn't be being
actively pursued until we've come to a
decision on this planning application
enforcement work will be
until we've determined whether or not
because if we were going to Grant
planning permission there'd be no point
in taking further enforcement action and
if we refuse then
we can proceed to further enforcement
action
I'll start with the aerial view of the
wider site
if I may so uh
it's not doing anything so to the south
of the site we have the edge of Ipswich
to the South West we'll have the White
House industrial estate and along
we've got a large residential estate to
the South and you can see the edge of
that
um at the very bottom well thank you
at the very bottom we then in The Wider
Countryside and surrounded by
agricultural Fields there's some there's
probiotic development along Thurston
Lane which runs down the frontage of the
site
here
and if we move on if we zero in we can
see the area of the application is
the access
this building
and the grounds of the site there are
two exceptions
here and here which would maintain their
lawful care home use
if we come to the constraints we've got
some
uh we've got a area TPO to the north of
the site but it does not encroach within
the site of the application we've also
got some public rights of way within the
wider Countryside but none of the cross
the site we've got no listed buildings
we have no uh areas of flood risk within
the site
I'll never come to the site plan again
you'll see the red line
as shown on the previous slides around
these two buildings so they would remain
care home use
we now turn to the proposed plans we
have
a large communal area for the HMO and
I'll show you in the site photos later
members uh sort of large glazed
Conservatory area we've then got
communal kitchen space and
the ground floor
and then we have more private rooms and
communal bathroom space on the first and
second floors
and then if we come to the parking plan
we
have parking for sole use of the HMO
residents visitors and then
others and then we've got the edge of
that red building
there which remain in its care home use
with regards to the principal
development officers are satisfied that
the principal development can be
supported and we've also had comments
from our private sector housing team to
say that in the time period that the HMI
has been operating on site they've had
no complaints with regards to its
operation or its use we've also sought
comments from our contacts at the police
and we have not had any response from
them
but we wouldn't necessarily expect to as
a designing our crime officer generally
looks at the layout of new Estates
making sure you know is there
one way in one way out for vehicles our
public rights away in our public areas
efficiently overlooked that sort of
thing
if we come to the entrance we've got two
brick plenty of the sides
quite a narrow entrance and I'll show
you the access way in later photos this
is the view to the south towards Ipswich
Nelson Lane is quite narrow it's a small
Countryside Lane
and there if we look towards the north
that's a view out into the Midsouth
district and again you can see the
Countryside in Vernon Lane
this is the access through the site it's
well treated
and there's a large grass area that I'll
show you in a moment then there's
um you can just Glimpse through
the trees the
communal space and then we have the rest
of the building stretching out our way
and we've got no external changes to the
building it's only internal changes that
have been made to the building and
that's
we're not able to
the parking areas while members
down on the right
if we come here this is the communal
shared area for external space
you can see again the communal shared
area internally and then you can see
part of the
part of the recommendation is for
approval we have a list of conditions on
there as well for members ensuring that
we
have the internal changes in accordance
with the approved plans that we've been
all the plans have been submitted we're
also looking to ensure that highways are
content that we have
provision of electric vehicle charging
points as well as cycle parking for the
residents and I'll come back to the
start of the photos I'll pass over to
members if there's any questions and I'm
happy to answer any questions it may
arise as a result of the report
thank you for that Daniel I did ask a
briefing did we know whether residents
did have vehicles whether some had them
or not I believe the applicants
here might be able to speak to that I
believe I believe
I believe some will
um
no and we're on the edge of Ipswich
we've got a good walking Connection in
even if we don't have
um made foot ways but I don't know if
we're going to be able to provide them
as a result of this application but yes
which certainly has a very frequent bus
service and then we'd have connection
into the railway Network as well in the
Town Center
um Daniel can you just confirm what did
you manage to check whether there had
been any serious accidents because the
parish casual had raised issues about
potential for that at all
yeah she's the last um
yes so as part of the report we've
analyzed the crash map data so
Department of Transport and the police
will feed into that there's been no
slight serious or fatal accidents on
this patch of Thurston Road since 2010
we do have the reports from the parish
council about
um issues and near-misses but if they're
not reported then they don't become part
part of the data set
um
things
come to the hall boys thank you
ah thank you
um this is a retrospective application
um yeah I'm very curious it's obviously
considerable scale this development that
as to why it's become a retrospective
development and not actually being
the timeline the application hasn't gone
through before I assume developments
started or completed so as I understand
it the applicant's taking possession of
the site on the understanding that the
HMO use of the
implemented my understanding is that it
had been granted a license for that use
but I think in looking back over the
particulars and in coming back to renew
the license they've discovered that
planning permission was never obtained
so the HMO use has been in place
we've had no complaints to our private
sector housing team in that time but in
terms of coming back to licensing and
getting everything agreed again
there has been this discrepancy plan so
this is why we have the application of
why we have it as retention of rather
than
viewing afresh before Works have been
carried out
I understand thank you
any further questions
thank you very much
we now move on to public speakers
and we have Parish Council Clayton
Parish Council councilor Stephen Wells
you have three minutes please okay thank
you Chuck before I start can I just
raise a couple of points
okay
are you ready
not get gone far away
the committee my name's Stephen Wells I
am a parish counselor I must also
declare a peculiary interest because I
live in the property directly opposite
the manner the development first of all
the parish was supportive of the
original application that went in 2016
which was for 18 Flats we would have
probably been continuing to be
supportive of this property being an HMO
if it's gone through the correct process
the community there is strong is good we
we don't particularly
with 40
50 made homeless however I employ the
committed to perhaps take a deferment on
this item until further information is
gathered because the information that
you've been provided with I genuinely do
not believe
the correct guidance or the information
to make a decision for example crash man
the crash map only covers 28 of all its
it has to be seriously
reported to the police there are
instance their vendor Benders every
other week that doesn't include the
horses the beers there is an issue with
the HMO how is the license people given
to an HMO that doesn't have HMO planning
permission
that means that there's no building
regulations to show that the structure
is suitable as an HMO and the license
has been given under the guise of the
enforcement agency being
Suffolk Coastal District Council which
of course doesn't exist
there are many many issues with this
application as a whole I don't think
many of us in the local community or
even the parish would have an issue with
it being an HTML however by going
through this route the developers are
evading the contributions to the
community by section 106 which was
signed as a deed to provide education
Library off-site affordable housing the
officers have stated that because it's
an HMO it comes under category 4 this is
not just an HMO this is a dual purpose
building because they have already puts
six Flats in there so there's six Flats
as residents then
[Music]
oh which means it's Dual Purpose if they
should apply for Dual Purpose use that
means that under planning consent or
reasonable consent in a x about two
years they'll be able to change those
into permanent residents as well I
employ to consider deferring this item
until you're able to gather to correct
and the detailed information that will
enable you to make a constructive
decision on how to
can I ask are you unwell
horrendously sorry chair this is not my
normal to me I have a daughter no I'm
just thinking of every member in here we
don't really want to sort of um
colds and stuff I I do understand the
administration
before haven't done me and let them know
that I was suffering from a cult
yes well thank you for that
um
I'm afraid some of us need to be
um isolating
um however I listened to your comments
that you're saying there and what um the
committee has to understand or will
understand is that licensing is a
separate issue and there will be a
separate licensing application moving
forward and often what happens is the
planning goes first and then if
licensing stops it then licensing stops
it and that's the way it goes so we can
approve
um without the licensing issue because
they are two separate things I'm also
chair of Licensing thank you
so if members have questions of the
gentleman would you like to ask the
questions
yes councilor man
yeah thank you chair just clarify you're
saying that there's been another
numb fender benders where people have
had a bump
um where's the exact location of this is
this coming out from the the Brick Gates
counselor um uh the officer showed you
some pictures of of two
two walls
this was a standard
we as a parent would probably have been
asking for consideration on community
investment and for those two walls to be
removed
because what it effectively means is on
the 10th wide leg
car has to nudge out his Bonnet four to
five foot before he could actually see
down the lane the uh bizarrely the
majority of the incidents happened that
I've seen as a nape happened to
Daylights because at least at night you
can see another car's lights coming up
up the lane
any further questions
I do understand your passion on I hear
the comments you make and thank you for
putting all those points to us
the applicant is here he's not going to
speak but um he can answer questions
should anybody have any questions now I
did have one question about
um I forgot what it was no in the car
parking wasn't it how many how many
people currently use the car park
good morning I'm Alan kale from the
owner of lime lease which is owned the
property since 1992.
one question I might and I can answer
your question yes there's a mixture of
people using cars they do walk up the
lane some people who haven't got cars
and also bicycles and probably from when
we ran it as a retirement home there's
probably about another 10 10 cars
actually on the site that used the lane
they talk about the brick wall can I
just comment on that we've actually
removed all we've moved all the hedging
so in fact you see the road before you
get to that brick wall and that brick
wall will be taken down as soon as we
get the road traffic situation sorted
it's just that all the signs are running
now but you have perfect view down the
lane as you come up to the brick wall
and you just stay behind the brick wall
and see if there's anyone coming then
come out so I've never heard none
yes it has that's before we actually
changed the front ready for the
development for the flats
officers that included in the plans
um it's not part of the conditions if
members wanted to make it part of the
conditions I think the only question
would be the time frame for removal
because we haven't got anything you know
we don't have building out the ground so
we don't have priority commencement or
slab level
we're looking at retention of we don't
have prior to occupation they're already
occupied we might just need to look at a
time period for that condition instead
but that could be delegated to officers
to speak to the applicant and agree if
members were so minded that
that was something but yes
yep thank you just uh one question to
the officer or officers probably given
that this is at committee because this
is an application for residential
development of 15 or more dwellings
uh
will the approval of this trigger the
sill process
I might have to come back to you on that
if that's all right if I can sorry Ian
well I
think I know that the answer is I'd
rather suddenly you definitely knew what
they were talking about answer I think
can we find an answer from our interest
during the meeting
Madam chairman if I may um as you're
aware I was on I wasn't able to come to
the briefing on on Monday but it sorry
if this is an obvious question I should
have sorted before the meeting but this
is this was a retirement home as the um
as the applicant has said which would
have been use class C2
I think that's right isn't it yeah and
it's the application is for a HMO
obviously a large HMO given its size and
office
I'm sorry if this is a very obvious and
foolish is that an office administering
the HMO or a separate Office business
use
okay
no it's the office for administering the
HMO right so it's not classy it's not a
separate classy use it's a it's but it's
yeah understand thank you sir
[Applause]
you're on sorry right uh thank you madam
chairman and good morning committee
members and you'll have read in your
report back today that from the
council's private sector housing team
that Woodlands has been successor in as
a HMO for the past five years and the
property provides much needed better
accommodation in the spacious rural
setting
a double room recently advertised for
440 pounds per calendar month on right
move describes Woodland Manor as
offering a Countryside feel with
Countryside field with fields
surrounding the premises
so I should probably say to members at
this point that I'm not looking to argue
against the officer recommendation on
this retrospective application
I for one would not like to see the
uncertainty that refusal might have on
its numerous tents
especially so close to Christmas
so you're probably wondering why I'm
taking the time to be here today just to
say that I'm here represented by local
community because there are some
concerns I'd like you to consider
to explain those I need to turn to the
planning history of this property so
Woodland Manor was a previously a
retirement at home which became empty an
application lodged in 2015 for change of
views from retirement home to 18 Flats
plus one staff flat and that permission
was granted on the 8th of April 2016.
subject as usual to a number of
conditions in the section 106 planning
obligation by deed
that permission clearly identified work
to be undertaken to the site's access
drawings showing the changes needed and
the required visibility displays in
addition a significant work was required
to create a 1.8 meter
wide foot way from the entrance
South to the 90 degree Bend in the road
along with proposed 5.1 meter widening
of the existing road so clearly a
significant expense for safety reasons
the section 106 agreements specified on
off-site affordable housing contribution
of 58 000 pound index linked
an education contribution of 12 181
pounds for Castle Hill School
a library contribution of 4104 pounds
for broomhill library and awaits
contribution of 969 pounds
all their sums being indexed linked
so this earlier permission came with a
number of benefits for the local
community a footpath road widening safe
aside access and egress and about 75 000
pound of monetary contribution towards
affordable housing education library and
waste
so it's earlier permission for 18 Flats
had conditioned as I said for wider
Community benefits
and um but this new permission in
contrast to 32 bed sets is conditioned
solely to just EV points on site and
cycle storage so these are merely
on-site resident benefits
now 18 flux compared to 32-bit bed sets
must surely have a similar economic
return in terms of rent
and a similar number of residents on
site
but this new retrospective application
appears to have eliminated all the
community benefits comes conditioned
under the earlier planning permission
so I ask on behalf of the local
community if you choose to follow off
the recommendations for approval are you
as members of this committee consent
content to see such reduced conditions
and financial contributions forthcoming
compared to the previous approved scheme
if so I feel that local the community
will feel short changed thank you
mentioned
thank you now questions for the ward
member
Council award boys thank you
in 2016
section 2 106 uh contributions weren't
made
by understanding because the looking at
the actual deed itself it said for
example the affordable housing would
only be payable on the first occupation
of the fourth property
and the other ones were only payable
after the first occupation of the first
property so on the basis that the
Planning Commission lapsed one assumes
that the section 106 indeed also lapsed
with it
that is the key point I'm making yes
I don't know if we've got some more
information here
oh sorry I thought it was relevant to
what we were doing I didn't want to miss
anything
right okay fine
so enough further questions
thank you yeah can I just make the point
I'm I'm almost answering my own question
uh I think yeah well yeah because it
hopefully will be Illuminating uh it's
saying
that there was a commuted sum secured
for affordable housing under the
previous permission
so are we saying that was secured or it
wasn't secured
uh
it also then goes on to say for the
purposes of planning policy a C3
residential joining would not normally
be required for to deliver an affordable
housing contribution
okay
if if that is the case
this shouldn't be a committee because
this is an application for one dwelling
is it not that has multiple occupancy
I think there's a bit of confusion I
stuck a little precise wording in the
scheme of Delegation so it talks about
so it's whether the
individual bedrooms within the HMO
constituted dwelling in and of
themselves or whether we're talking
about this being one dwelling I I think
for transparency and openness possibly
it's better to have that better that
increased level of scrutiny just to make
sure that
we are okay on that one
sorry am I switched on now
still in the point of some uncertainty
I'm just looking I was just looking at
um
there is a existing building credit
which is quite useful to people
sometimes but I think I'm just mindful
it's only applies when the building's
been lawfully in use for a period of
time before permission is granted in
this case it was a retirement home but
it isn't any longer and the HMO use
it may not be anybody's fault in
particular we don't need to go into that
but it was it's a retrospective
application so I'm I'm rather off the
top of my head in the middle of a
meeting I'm rather doubtful about as to
whether that applies
um I think we have tried to contact us a
colleague in the infrastructure team
who's not immediately available it's
quite an important point I realize for
members Madam chair we can try a bit
harder in the moment over that
and yes indeed is it it's we're just
trying one person or is it just the
whole team not available can we the
manager was in the meeting wasn't she
started a meeting is it is it a virtual
meeting
do we know
um
because if it's a virtual meeting we can
interrupt it sorry councilor just to
sort of amplify I mean it says from the
Strategic housing comments because what
I'd expect if we were getting 32 units
coming up I would expect to be some of
them to be affordable units given given
they are all relatively affordable to
start with but
we yeah it doesn't matter so
and what they're saying is because we
secured a commuted some last time means
we're not going to seek anything this
time but if we didn't secure the sum
last time
should we be seeking some this time
I don't want to debate it any further at
the moment but
that was in different ownership
yeah but I don't know whether it went
through
um Ian what do you recommend shall we
debate going forward and find out if we
can find the answer to that question
yes I think that would be the best thing
who would like to start I think we're
there aren't we open up the debate yes
who would like to start the debate and
we'll try and find the answer to that
question before we come to a conclusion
anyone Council Caston thank you
um thank you madam chairman
um uh to be honest my decision
completely hangs on this situation we've
got here which um
um I think that's the um the absolute
Crux of the
of this application obviously
um we need to if if if it hasn't been
secured
um this um there's some section 106 and
cell and um things we we really need to
deal with that um
the only other thing that I can um
see looking at the application
is that the um those brick walls that
the um Parish Council talked about they
don't look like anything old or precious
or anything like that and I do think
they pose a a you know a danger to
Vehicles pulling out so I don't know if
we're able to do that
in conditions but I'd like to um I'd
like to see them removed to just make it
much safer for cars coming down the lane
and um cars pulling out they do um I'm
looking at a Google Earth picture of
them at the moment and they do they do
almost completely cover a cyclist or a
or a car pulling out of there
um
but that's not the big issue we've got
here and um I will wait to um get more
information on
nice and some others
the lines of councilor Caston if that's
going to be the case if you just want a
10 minute break while we try and find
the answer if we can't find the answer
to that then I'm afraid we'll have to go
for a deferral because you know there's
no point in wasting time
oh beg your pardon here we go so sorry
so we just
um questioned a few members of the
infrastructure team but we've not heard
back but instead we've gone straight to
Community infrastructure Levy uh
charging schedule so that's set out what
we are seeking uh payments for and the
sell rates are pretty universally set on
C3 develop
open market
residential units there's no provision
for C4 development which nhmo would be
to or generous if we're yeah to to make
that same
payment and then obviously it's
um Council Whitehead was mentioning the
um
scheme to develop Flats on the site has
elapsed and the section 106 has also
elapsed so the
the benefits under that section 106 have
also
past
those two
C3 but excluding specialist older
persons housing and and other
development that isn't anywhere near
this
this is retail so it's the charge
doesn't arise in the first place
so my worry about it
well I think that makes it a lot clearer
and it's um and thank you very much to
um the team for looking into that and
getting us such clear information
um so um
yeah I well I think that that does that
does change things and I don't think
I've got too many issues but I would
like to see that um that woolum removed
but I'll I'll listen to other members of
the committee and or and listen to
whether that's actually possible with
this
um did we have an issue from County
highways regardless
one of the things that we might be a bit
so in response to the application County
highways wanted to see the
um are shown in the submitted drawings
be provided on site
as you've seen from the photos the
access is provided on site and the way
that it's shown in the drawings is how
it's
on site at the moment so it didn't seem
to be necessary to impose a condition to
secure that given that it's already in
place but if members then felt that a
condition was required to remove the
brick see the side of the access to
further improvisibility which the
applicant has already said is part of
their plan then I feel that officers
could
word a suitable condition to make sure
that that happens in a timely manner
Stu but everybody too so thank you for
raising that councilor Stringer then
counselor um thank you chair well thank
you for clearing up the sill Arrangement
so obviously the Strategic housing
comments are then not correct that first
sentence is not correct it wasn't
secured because we didn't get it
and that was that was that was the basis
of their judgment
so the basis of the Strategic housing
comment is is based on
something that's incorrect they were
suggesting we don't need to seek any
affordable units here because there was
a commuted sum that was secured as part
of the last application
well it wasn't secured we didn't get it
so for my I mean it could be argued that
these units are relatively affordable
but that that may change what you what
we're approving is what we're approving
and we we don't normally approve this
number of units without seeking an
affordable contribution or at least some
of them being defined as affordable or
let out under an RSL or something like
that uh
they didn't have an office to do it from
there's
and equally if it's not going to bring
about Community benefits how does the
community that live here
benefit where do the children play that
live here
how did I get to the nearest place for
recreation
if they can't get there because there's
no infrastructure payment coming then it
needs to provide it on site there's a
whole load of questions that come out of
that question being answered incorrectly
for me anyway so that's where I am thank
you
thank you for that anybody else wish to
comment counselor
thank you chair thank you for clarifying
the situation regarding the war and I
think if we can have that as a condition
I think that'll be really helpful but
going after what character string I
would say does say sort of end these
below that
um a C3 residential dwelling which would
normally be required to provide an
affordable housing country either
through on-site delivery or Community
sums and HMO for avoid update is a c4u
so I gather for what Daniel was saying
we don't need that contribution
no so uh yes it's not a C3 use that
would normally attract the 35
policy requirement and I think the other
thing to mention that I didn't pick up
on from
councilor wells's point is that if we
were to see a change of use
from this building to move it into a C3
use to convert it into flats that would
need to come back if it's over 15 and we
need to come back to members we would
still have the same calling procedure if
we wanted it to come back before members
even if it was under that threshold and
if we're triggering any thresholds for
affordable housing or other section 106
requirements we'll then need to go
through that process as well but that
would require a further application it's
not
there is some scope to move from an HMO
to a C3 use but that genes to be for
smaller hmos and there's a limit of up
to six
you can go in total and if we're dealing
with something that's much larger in
terms of
uh 30 plus units
and that's
almost definitely going to need a fresh
occasion
thank you for that who else would like
to speak thank you anyone else
councilman
yeah I find myself a little bit confused
by this and hopefully officers and maybe
the applicant can provide some clarity
um
yeah okay
so
um
the original application which came in
2015 was the change of use to 18 flats
and one star flat
and the accusation or the the the point
was made by the community representative
that that had already been partly
completed and now they're switching to
an HMO to try and avoid
uh
the extra Community benefits and
contributions that were
that were agreed under the section 106.
so
I'll be there councilor when the first
application came in just to correct in
my mind because I'm going the timeline
wasn't that a different owner well
that's what I just wanted to clarify
because I'm not sure that your comments
saying that somebody's doing something
to avoid something well I'm just wanting
to understand what's happened and
the place have been in their ownership
since 2002.
clearly the section 106 is dated 2016.
so I've just wanted to understand the
sequence of events
if that's possible to get some
clarification on that
so my understanding is that we granted
permission
flaps we secured the section 106 and
then given that
that hasn't then been brought forward my
understanding was that the building
remained in its care home use
so with the lapse of the planning
permission the section 106 also falls
away
and although we have
um some element of
flat shown on the
my understanding is that this is the
change of European care home to HMO
there's not been a partial
implementation of
the previous permission but we can turn
to the applicant as well for
confirmation on that I was just going to
say in view of the um uncertainty we we
can ask the applicant as he's sitting
here just to answer that briefly for us
please because we don't normally ask you
to speak again
the actual question was whether I owned
it right the way through that is correct
the it wasn't my decision to not be able
to go forward with the development of
the flats unfortunately Ipswich Council
to widen the road
and as soon as that condition wasn't
going to be complied with I had to then
put it on hold and the only other way of
continuing with the building when I
purchased it there were people in
Residence already from the people who
owned it prior to me
and I just assumed they'd already got
change of use for residential use and
then we just carried on and with
Christine Ambrose's help continued it to
a five-year HMO to the level that the
council required
so I'm sorry it was she did send a
letter to the planning and didn't get a
response back saying and so she's
concerned that change of views hadn't
been made and so I just carried on
assuming it had already been made
and I'm quite happy to take the brick
walls down by the way that is part of
our plan that sounds good does that help
counselor I think it's made it clearer
for me as well yeah I think
clarify it a little bit and the other
question just in my mind is that the
sequence of events to do with licensing
because I think you mentioned previously
that licensing can follow
a planning application but here we seem
to have it the other way around do we
understand how that's
what Madam chair I think um
I used to deal with private sector
housing a lot in previous employment
I've not generally done it for this
Council
I think I mean without being rude to
anybody in an ideal world it would have
been realized sooner that planning
permission was necessary but I don't
think there's any as as with alcohol
licensing which the chairman and vice
chairman I know are very familiar with
why I would certainly myself on the
other side of the fence I would advise a
business client to get the planning
permission sorted first but it's not
separate areas of law although admitted
by the same Council it's not legally
wrong to do one without the other
and just to correct I was told at
briefing that the application for the
licensing would be coming after the
planning it's
because I did ask the questions
so there's still there's still um
can officer and legal advisor still sort
of a backstop that might resist this
application if planning were approved
and the licensing didn't approve it
that's right there's various points in
licensing that would come back and have
a separate review and it's the old
Chestnut that planning can only deal
with our bit of legislation and
Licensing needs still with their own but
there's usually various Consultants I
think possibly
um the only reference date that there
was maybe not responsible planning last
time it never got definitely confirmed
one way or the other
we're now in a different position and we
need dining out and that was the correct
process to do the planning and then come
back for a further license for another
five years down or in a bit more
into the debate I'm sorry you know we've
um already had one session
experience yeah yeah can I just now I've
gone through the timeline that's
actually really really helpful
can we then agree can the officers agree
that the all of the comments from
strategic housing are actually incorrect
may I Madam chair um I think if so I was
going to jump in and give some advice on
this just for the sake of absolute
Clarity I think members we have reached
a point where we do understand the
situation factually now so
you see on page 16 the report the
reference to three permissions in the
planning history one is a very old one
1986 that we we presume doesn't
um court have is there for for
completeness the reference to 98215
change of use and retirement home to 18
flats and the staff flat that was
permission granted subject to a commuted
sum and I think you under it's
understood a commuting some is not sill
a commuted sum is what is often fairly
often occurs where actual on-sites
housing affordable housing provision as
in reservation of certain units for a
social provider cannot be practically
achieved so instead you have money paid
a commuted sum but because the
permission was not implemented I assume
the planning obligation never kicked in
so it's it's history and so Council
Stringer has a fair point there
so yeah yeah so that's I think that's
the best advice I can give at the moment
actually I was I was also now referring
to the second point in that the other
reason for not pursuing this was because
there's no increase in units well there
are it's going from 18 to 32. so all of
that advice is actually incorrect
but it might be trumped by the advice
that hmos you cannot seek an affordable
housing contribution or on-site
contribution but I would have expected
that to have been in the advice and
confirm that Daniel
perhaps you've been I think there it
comes back to a degree to the uh the
conversation we perhaps had over the uh
referral to committee about the
dwellings there is a different
definitions at times and I think
possibly this has been looked at as
C3 without that understanding that as C4
and that slight difference so yes I
appreciate that has suggested changing
units in the previous community so I
think we're clear and and to be fair
strategic housing had not asked for
anything and I think that's clear for us
that we wouldn't seek anything on a C4
either through seal or through section
106 because that's a slightly different
use but I think that dwelling is
oddly
um one of those naughty problems that
doesn't quite follow through for us but
yes I would suggest none of that
sorry
um means that we would need to seek
anything on this case
so with this information that we are
either happy or unhappy with
can we move forward on the debate and
neither go one way or the other on it
because I don't think you know we've
we've had the legal advice that we've
got
and councilor Kasten sorry
yeah I think um the important thing is
that the committee now is absolutely
clear on how how this um works and it
was unfortunate that maybe that the um
papers were a bit confusing
um
I think there are several benefits to
this there's the um there's a route
there's a need for this type of housing
there's a um you know it's obviously um
lower cost than um normal housing it's a
um it's a lifestyle Choice the buildings
the building's there to do it
the um I think the um removal of that
wall I'd like to see conditioned
um because I think not only does that
make it safer it also improves the look
of the whole place
um
so um yeah it is um
it's unfortunate that the um the
community won't benefit but that's
obviously very clearly um not something
that happens with this but there is a
massive benefit in the fact that we have
affordable work not not the general term
affordable but affordable to um
to um renters
um you know accommodation so on that
basis
I'd like to propose that um we approve
this
um with the condition of the wool um set
in stone
um
no the condition of knocking down a wall
being set in stone which is some quite
quite a confusing way of voting it
um and I'm happy to listen to any other
conditions that members see fit to um
put on there as as this develops but
yeah I'd like to um I'd like to propose
approval
thank you
chair yes um well we know from the
papers that um there's been no issues
with the residents at this address for
the five years and we the last thing we
want is for these people to be made
homeless it's been clarified with the
physician as it stands now and thank you
thank you for that so I agree with
councilor custard that we perhaps should
have a condition regarding the war being
removed the applicant who said he's
prepared to do that so I'm happy to
Second The Proposal chair thank you
thank you very much for that I haven't
actually spoken so um I normally leave
it to the end but I think we're sort of
getting there um I had an exact issue in
debenham and we lost payment on it
because there was change of ownership or
there was change of use and there was a
lot of money lost and these things
happen they get tied up in sort of
difficult timelines but I think I'm with
councilor Kasten there's homes for these
people and
um
incumbent on us to make sure they still
have homes I can't see there's anything
too
serious that we can't amend the brick
wall so I would be voting for this
anybody else wishing to speak Council of
War boys
yes
um yes I I agree I think I think this um
development does meet a community lead
and it's an appropriate site I think I'd
just like to
I in some of the community benefits or
improvements to [ __ ] Pass Road widening
which was
hesitate to use what's covered by
Suffolk highways
um
uh I think I could see the the betsets
has been a contribution to affordable
housing
um looking at the pictures of the
roadways on the the actual site itself
I I might suggest that there's some
provision for
uh pedestrians and
cyclists along those roads is that is
that feasible
come on
well however have already said they
can't widen the road so I don't know
what an earth
they're actually using it at the moment
it's whether or not it is reasonable to
require the widening of the internal
access roads
um
and provision of a footwear along that
there is
um
substantial grass area on either side so
there is pedestrian Refuge along there
um
and it would
I can see why members want to see that
betterment
but without being able to secure the
complete walking route into Ipswich
um
you sort of
take a made foot way to an area where
we're never going to be able to secure
it because the
landowner that would be required to give
permission has already shown through the
previous section 106 that they're
unwilling to give
that permission for the widening and
provision of a footpath
we could see if the applicant was
willing to provide it
I don't know that it's necessary
um
and in any case it would
would finish up on a narrow Country Lane
without a laid footpath
um
thank you sorry thank you um yeah I
completely understand what counts the
war boys is saying with this um
the um
the route into Ipswich is about 180
meters I believe with um but it's a
fairly straight road it is
a difficult Road it's it's very thin
it's not a great Road for um walking
down but it is straight
um as far as I can see and um I don't
believe that that
is an Inc you know a particularly
dangerous road for mid-suffolk I think I
think um I I think maybe um the crash
Maps um
um we'll talk about car accidents but
I'm thinking purely people cycling or
walking into Ipswich and I I I just
don't think there's anything that can be
done about it I'd love to say yeah a
footpath down there or um a um you know
a footpath across the field or something
it's just not within what we can do on
an internal footpath I just don't I
don't know what counts the war boys
thinks about that but I just don't think
that really addresses the problem that
you're talking about because cars are
already
um quite
managed coming in and out of there it's
it's on the actual road but I just don't
see how there's anything we can do about
it but it is
is a problem that can't be fixed as far
as I can see but I don't see it's a big
enough problem to be an issue with thank
you thank you for your comments too but
I don't think we need to sort of dwell
on things that we can't do and I
appreciate your comments and councilor
War boys thoughts too does anyone else
wish to speak to the motion before we go
to the vote because I think we've quite
um exhausted this one yes
just to clarify it says existing I'm
trying to look through the plans the
link by the way doesn't work so I'm
sitting here not able to look at the
plans only other on a tiny mobile phone
which I think is not brilliant frankly
it and I interrupt you I was going to
ask at the end of this meeting something
about that yeah
emails we are slightly running risks in
terms of well I'm sure we're on this one
on the planet I can see and it's
difficult to The annotation it shows six
Flats in here
so it isn't all HMO I think we were
under the apprehension that it was all
HMO can we just have Clarity on that
yeah well it's actually three uses on
here
there were three uses okay
all right
okay
foreign
the the threshold within the mppf is 10
or more
so until we get to but again if we were
to get a subsequent planning permission
for change of use to Flats on the fourth
new flat that would then
trigger requirement and be looking at
the entire the entire provision of the
site
and this was all in the application when
we had the application before us so I
think can we move on please obviously
councilor stringers are puzzled about it
and unhappy with it
um does anyone else wish to speak
no right thank you very much can we go
to the vote on this one please thank you
would you do you want the condition read
out regarding the brick wall do we have
something there yeah
yeah thank you madam chairman yeah I
would quite like to hear it
um yeah
yeah um so I'm looking at proving as the
recommendation on page 19 with an
additional condition
um I put us the notice to secure removal
of wall
um for the minute in terms of what we
might look at is that within a certain
amount of time following the grinder
Planning Commission we normally do three
months but I think that's something if
members of contempt we could take away
and agree with the applicant in what
time they would agree to do so so we
would get a plan of work from them of
well I can't do it now because it's the
winter but we could do it you know an
appropriate time we would agree that
time to get the removal of the wall
secured so essentially I'm suggesting we
delegate to sort out the wording of the
condition but in that kind of scenario
is that enough
yeah does that include foundations
coming out when we say removal of the
wall we can absolutely specify that if
that's what you like
if it helps members debate the highway
Authority where they're looking secure
visibility is normally saying nothing
higher than 0.6 meters above ground
level
so we could secure that it's when the
members want to secure something lower
than that as well so whether we do want
to go down to ground level or whether we
do want to remove it but in the wording
we could agree
scheme of works
I personally would like it completely
removed because I think it um improves
the look of that very um you know um
green nice area of the lane and I'd like
to see the foundations removed as well
because they'll be quite substantial
foundations for that wall which will
leave for the concrete area which could
not look particularly nice um as well so
um if if members are happy to vote on
that um and my second is Happy
um could I suggest possibly making good
afterwards as well so we're not left
with something as well so we're looking
at removing the wall to include the
foundations and subsequently making good
yeah thank you
yeah that sounds good worries me is
going to be a great big hole right
can we go
thank you chair and then there's that
vote is now in progress
councilor Gould
your votes don't come through for me
the chair so that makes six votes for
one against and one abstention
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed everyone and
we're now back
to here the second application DC
2202924 land off Jack's Green Road
greetings Saint Mary now councilor
Norris
um I believe you need to be sitting in
the ward member Department don't you
do you want your computer with you
counselor can someone carry it for him
no
he's all right with his papers go
so I'll now um and
it's fine I'll now invite the case
officer Daniel
to introduce the next uh matter please
thank you
thank you chair um this application is
for Reserve matters
you've got appearance access scale
layout and landscaping for up to 43
dwellings
um with regards to the report there's
one thing to report uh members and that
is with regards to the comments of the
lead local flood Authority so you'll
note in the papers that they've given us
a holding objection
um
and I've noted beneath that we've had
the detail that the lff llfa require as
part of a discharge or conditions
application that sits alongside this and
it's part of the report that speaks
about that and within that the llfa have
said yes this is acceptable um
back from them to show that the holding
objection on this application can be
removed and we can move forward
so this came before members of B
committee on 4th September 2019
um where we approved outline we've got
this site
here we've got a modern estate
to the immediate South down St Mary's
way we've got access into need a market
after about a kilometer that brings you
past the entrance to older car farm and
then up into Needham Market past the
three tons Public House and the co-op is
done just a short walk from there and
then as well we've got the flyover over
the A14 and to creating Saint Mary up
the hill here and I'll show you that
more in uh
the site images later in the report
members
if we take a slightly wider view we
still can't see the edge of creeks at
Mary but we do get the edge of need and
Market here and then we've got the edge
of the brahini site
here which we've approved for 52
dwellings I think
52 units and then if we look at the side
location plan we've got some adjoining
development
here and I'll show that in the
site images for numbers as well
and then in terms of constraints uh
we're adjacent to the built-up area
boundary
we're outside the special landscape area
we don't have any listed buildings from
the site but we do have flood zone two
and three crossing the site and they
follow the line of a drainage ditch
through the site which is very faint on
your
is their members but I'll show you that
in the site photos to come as well
if we look at the emerging joint local
plan as well the site is included within
the boundary there but obviously it's
Yet to Come forward and be adopted
this is the indicative plan that we
approved outline
um the red line indicates the extent of
the flood zone all the housing is
outside of the flood zone
we've got one access in for the housing
and then we've got a separate access
along here that gives access to this
open space and we've got provision of
play Space within that area as well
there was a section 106 secured at
outline stage that provides affordable
housing on site as well as maintenance
of the play area and open space within
the site as well members
uh we then move on to the post site
layout it is broadly similar with the
indicative again we have the housing
outside of the flood zone
arranged in this portion of the site and
then we have
the open space further north and I'll
show you when we get to the Landscaping
clan members we also have
some equipped play areas here there's a
requirement in terms of noise for a bond
to be erected around the perimeter of
the site an acoustic fence will be
placed on top of that and then they'll
be planting around and On the Bun to
help secure it as well and to give it a
more green and verdant appearance the
provision of that bond is to come
forward quite quickly within the
development of the site in that we'll be
using the soil from the site itself to
then provide the bond and within the
Landscaping specifications we've got top
soil being placed fresh on top of the
Buns so that the Landscaping on there
Will be able to establish
we've got 100 air source heat pumps
within the scheme members we don't have
any provision for solar panels but we do
have 100 electric vehicle charging
points as part of the discharge of
conditions application we've got
sustainability scheme that's been
assessed by your environmental health
team and they consider it to be in line
with what they would require in terms of
reduction of
in terms of making sure that we adhere
to the higher standards of building
regulations to make sure we've got as
much uh thermal insulation on the
buildings as possible
um
in terms of the access Works highways
are happy they've given us some
conditions to secure
and you know get some additional
walkways around
and then we've also got
um biodiversity within the site so we've
got bat boxes bird boxes integrated into
the fabric of the build as well so we
have that secured and that was
recommended by Play services ecology at
outline stage so we've got the detail
for them now and again they're happy
with the biodiversity detail that we've
managed to secure
um with regards to the Landscaping plan
we've had comments from our public realm
team they're happy with the play
facilities at this end and with the
access and ability to park their
vehicles for maintaining it they've
asked whether some additional natural
um play equipment
fell trees borders that sort of thing
could be implemented Within part of the
open space and prior to the meeting The
Agency Group that through condition we
can bring that forward as well for you
members
if we look at the site photos I've
included them both from the outline
stage which were taken in the winter of
2019
and from
um more recently in the summer so we can
have an idea of what the vegetation
looks like across the scheme so this is
from the edge of the site flordon road
is just to my right and this is looking
up towards the A14 there's this dense
Bank of tree growth that's intended to
be retained on the site through
development
um the line of the drainage Stitch just
runs across here following the
electricity poles and then this is
looking up towards the other end of the
site we've got the housing off on the
left hand side
this is the run of the ditch itself
during winter not particularly
um full but it was quite a dry winter
and obviously we do have the flood zone
maps to show the stand up
and our spill out
and then these are the neighboring
dwellings on the other side we've got
extensive boundary planting secured
within this scheme so that there is a a
boundary between
this scheme and its neighbors
and then this is the view up so this is
the road that would lead down to need a
market members and then this is
through to the
uh this is the view the other way and
this is now
2022 so this is the view down flordon
Road this is the access up to creating
Saint Mary and the
brick at the end there
again this is sort of the similar images
across the site that we've seen
previously so we've got the drainage
ditch
we can see the A14 in the distance
obviously we'll have a three meter high
Bond and then an acoustic fence and then
tree planting on the edge as well to
further screen that protect the
dwellings from noise
there you can see the
dance patch of tree growth is set to be
retained within the scheme
up over to the neighbors
um I don't know if you can make it out
in this image members but there's the
poster rail fence and then one of the
neighbors to the site keeps horses in
this field and they've been very
concerned about ensuring that we have
sufficient separation if we you know
bring in more residential use in their
concern about the health of their horses
but in terms of the height of the bond
and the acoustic fence the additional
planting they're secure that
and this one really wants to
find those horses they'll be secure and
protected and more insulated from passes
by than they maybe are at present
this is the run of the drainage ditch
again up through
think you can just spot a horse off in
the left-hand side I'm not sure
um this is the view uh up towards the
greetings and then again we've got the
access road down to Mary's way down into
Needham Market
and then the view across the site again
their members I've got some house types
they're broadly reminiscent and
characterful of the area you've got a
lot of modern
um
render and brick buildings and this is
what we have
um within here as well I'll flick
through them and if there's any need to
go back and give a specific comment on
them I'll flow back and give specific
comment on them as we need them we've
got some uh Bungalows within the scheme
as well members and that's all detailed
within the report in front of you as
well I'll go back to the pictures but if
we need anything else
I'll pass back to members and if they've
got any questions arising for report
I'll be happy to answer them
thank you for that Daniel of course I'm
going to ask the question about when is
the band and the planting going in to
sort of protect the neighboring
landowner with her horses so that's very
I showed up early within the build
s we've got the agent here who might be
able to give more detail when we get to
that point
um I think it will be
a little bit of a movable piece I don't
know if I'd be able to give an exact Buy
a scheduled very early within the site
because they need to get the
Bund in place and they need to make sure
that the angle of the soil is such that
it supports its own weight with the
fence and the additional planting so
that that will be a big big machinery
but then once you've got that you have
that additional screening from the
horses as well
yeah I understand that they've already
made contact with the site manager and
have a good relationship with them so
yeah thank you chair just a couple of
questions about design uh the first one
it said it's typical of Suffolk design
one
uh there's over five meters of clear 45
degree roof there
I
that's not typical of Suffolk that's
that's a very very tall building
uh topping out nearly 8.3 meters
that's quite substantial uh glazed
balconies as well I can see not typical
of Suffolk also want to make the point
integral garages in a rural Village
is that I mean normally don't we see
integral garages in urban settings I
thought we had a design issue with
integral garages we also have some of
these uh bedrooms above garages which I
thought
we were
not doing for insulation purposes you
know they
they will need to be incredibly
insulated for fire as well as trying to
keep the buildings warm
and equally I've picked out some of the
designs in terms of possible solar
paneling in the future and it looks like
plot 31 32 34 35 29 28 37 0702 41 40 and
39 you basically output no solar panels
on them at all because the south facing
roof is a question or a statement no no
I'm asking is this you know the sort of
have we taken that into account to say
this design is appropriate and could it
be designed any other way for you
so in terms of uh how typical the design
is it's obviously a more modern estate
but it is seen in the context of the
1960s estate at St Mary's
um and in that context we've got similar
um
designs there
um in terms of integral garages we do
have
marriages but then that's
necessary if we're going to deliver the
EV charging points
um and we do have some bent over garages
but they would be required to adhere to
building regs in terms of their
insulation as well in terms of
ensuring fire risk is satisfactorily
addressed
check if I could can I just come back
the the existing is in this similar in
design yeah what I was questioning was
the height the the building I can see on
the photograph is about five meters tall
these are over 3.3 meters taller than
those
um
I'm not objecting I'm just asking has
that been taken care is that appropriate
because they it just seemed incredibly
human well I think that's something for
debate about whether you like the design
or not whether the officer is obviously
looked at the distance we do have a good
degree of separation
um from the neighboring dwellings to the
Northwest
um so that we wouldn't have any issues
with overlooking in that regard we do
have
buildings to the south of Florida road
that there would be some mutual Overlook
but in terms of front to front there's
no minimum distance in you know at the
same time you might want that element of
natural surveillance
as well we do have a good array of
orientations of roof slopes to allow
some solar to come forward on the scheme
we don't have
um 100 south facing roofs across the
entirety of the scheme where we've got
East-West it might just be if anything
gets installed there that peak of power
generation comes at a different point in
time but I'll take
I'm trying to find Mike can I come but
can you just explode that can you zoom
in on that it's almost like the majority
of the rooms have been designed where
they do face South to put Dormer windows
in them to preclude the ability to put
solar panels on
you're now entering debate let's let's
just wait until we get into debate
you've asked the question have they
taken it into account and I think the
answer is yes they have and we'll come
on to your point in debate if we may are
there any more specific questions
Council custom
that was a really good picture to
um use for this question it's um
thank you
um the boundary on the back on the backs
of the gardens and those trees down
there
um what is that boundary uh made of and
um are those trees and the ownership of
the houses
um or are they the other side in the in
the green space please
I believe the trees are in the ownership
of the open that will be managed by the
management company so that it wouldn't
be then if can come out and be room
be remember just see if I can get the
Landscaping plan up for you because that
will then let me zoom in
counselor I can't
oh I don't know how to do it on that bit
and then the boundary treatment along
there is all to be a native Hedgerow and
that's to come along the frontage as
well so it'll be
green and verdant rather than a hard
um
close body fence or or a brick wall yeah
thanks
thank you
further questions for the officer
thank you very much
yeah yeah
so we have the applicant
um patiently waiting for a Sebastian
blemings please if you'd like to give us
your three minutes uh summing up of
what's on offer to us thank you
good morning everybody my name is
Sebastian blemings I'm here from sjb
designs we're the agents uh for the
development in Jackson Bean Road with
proposal for up to 43 dwellings
I'm here to represent the applicant Ruby
homes who are a local building developer
located just outside Needham Market less
than four miles away from the proposed
development site
the principle of development was
obviously agreed previously at the
outline planning stage
which was
agreed at this development committee and
this application seeks to address the
reserve matters
there is concurrent discharge conditions
planning application which addresses
many of the console T queries that
appear to have not been resolved
although these have all been agreed as
part of the discharge which Daniel
obviously explained earlier
um going on from that the development
allocates 15 number Affordable
units which Accord with the section 106
agreement both in terms of size and
number of units the other 28 units
will all be liable for Community
infrastructure Levy charges
in conjunction with the current sign
toner the development will result in a
further six units being used as arms
houses
the development will be sustainable with
each of the properties being heated with
air source heat pumps with the built-in
envelopes being highly insulated which
results in an improvement above Target
emission rates of over 20 percent
what the properties have also been
designed to exceed targets for water use
with each property being designed at 110
liters of water per person per day which
is an improvement on the standard 125
liters per person per day
each of the properties will have
electric car charging infrastructure and
and all of this information is available
part of the reserve matters uh
information and the discharge of
condition
s application
um information that's pretty much it but
obviously have to answer any questions
I'm sure there might be a couple of
questions questions
um from the committee Council
and you can't answer for a question I'm
sure I can see one coming
yes councilor Stringer uh sorry sir you
you've heard it before I'm trying to get
it up on this phone and it's very
difficult to get the plan in any kind of
time
I just want to clarify with how many
rooms have been designed that could in
future
have solar panels and it does seem like
an awful lot of them have been designed
where that that would preclude that
happening they've not been designed
um specifically to avoid or or for
um the the principle was to
um design the houses to be sustainable
so through the built envelope the the
idea is that we obviously use less
energy
rather than generate electricity
yeah but that that's fine for now but in
future if we could design them that they
could carry it they would then be even
would they not be even more sustainable
I can't disagree with that yeah I'm just
saying that when this scheme was
prepared it wasn't prepared on on that
Proviso okay
okay all right thank you
thank you for that
and there's a personal Secret prompt as
well isn't it that's uh obviously very
uh acceptable and Well Done
um any further questions no
all right we have the ward member
councilor Norris would you like to tell
us your thoughts on this application
thank you
chair
I have a number of concerns regarding
this application
um as previously mentioned in the final
application presentation uh the site
Falls outside the assessment boundaries
by the cretenc Mary or need a market and
therefore is in conflict with policy
cs02 development in the countryside and
Countryside villages
I haven't seen any evidence in the
papers of any proven need for
development in this particular location
no public transport serves the site and
any future residents would for all
purposes be dependent on the use of
private cars to access local facilities
such as the doctor's surgery which is
located at the southern end of Needham
Market
this conflicts with the aims of the
national planning policy framework to
Aspire to a low-carbon economy and also
policy CSO three
reduce contributions to climate change
over development the online amended site
layout plan shows a proportion of three
four and five bedroom houses on a site
on Rising ground
this would be a keeping with existing
Residential Properties in the immediate
area of which there are considerable
number of single story Bungalows and
Chalet Bungalows and this additional
conflict with policy age 13 design and
load of Housing Development and policy
h15 development to reflect local
characteristics
I have to question the statement on page
31 and paragraph 6.4 that housing is
typically two-story in height much from
the overall character of the surrounding
area
I know the area well in fact I took a
drive around there this morning I
actually refresh myself of the details
there are considerable number of
Bungalows along Jack's Green Road and
Saint Mary's Road including Saint Mary's
Gardens which is almost entirely
bungalows
um I would draw members attention to the
parish council's comments on page 25
third paragraph down
access stroke on suitable Road Chuck's
Green Road is already a very busy road
with an ongoing speeding issue date of
retrieved from the vehicle activated
speed sign located on Jack's green
triangle has presented to us how
motorists ignore the speed limit
improves what a dangerous road it can be
adding another 100 plus vehicles to the
mix will certainly make the road even
more dangerous
there is also the cumulative effect on a
village with limited facilities
of several previous applications on All
Saints Road greens and Mary
and 52 houses on the brahani site in
Florida Road
which leads to Jack's Green Road a very
short distance away but the rohini site
has already been approved at is being
built out at this time
I think that's all I need to say at this
point
um uh for the reasons I've mentioned I
cannot support this application thank
you uh thank you councilor Norris I mean
your first statements uh We've sort of
covered this that outline has already
been granted
um but I hear what you say because click
because clearly the
sorry
what's that
sorry but I was going to say I hear what
you say for your residence I'm sure they
still have that anxiety but we have
already approved and this is uh for the
reserved matters but your points are
well heard thank you
no no but you're you're
um Community would want you to tell us
and remind us about that so that's most
that's understood
um do we have questions for uh councilor
Norris as such
no
right
well the item is open for debate then
please who would like to start the
debate
councilor custom thank you
I might be um
being a bit stupid here but um when I am
looked at the affordable housing layout
on this the plan looks different to the
one we've been looking at
um here and I don't know quite what I've
done but I just wanna
clear that up before I am I've been
looking at a different map of the um
the the plans to that
um
that one we've been looking at
um and that's from on the website
this up about that um we haven't got all
the papers and there's the link and my
link didn't work
um so I'm not sure if anyone else um
could you put up that plan there there
it is and that's you you're saying the
one you've got is different yeah and it
doesn't say superseded or anything and
but um I I've seen the um
I've seen what I'm looking at is the
um the one from the outline that's maybe
changed or something possible possibly
so we do have the indicative outline
part of this and it is similar
um we have had some revisions to
drawings as we've gone through and
negotiated the scheme as well um ones
I've got within the presentation within
this application and the most up-to-date
ones
um
regards to that layout
affordable housing and are they not on
the website then is that not on the
website no these are all on the website
there's just quite a lot of plans
it's just if the general public are
looking at them they need to look at the
same ones that we're looking at now
don't they
even um yeah that that map looks
different to the one with the trees on
is um it's quite um confusing but I
assume that the um
sorry if you don't mind me asking
questions
I assume of that picture the affordable
housing is still in a line alongside the
A14 like it like this one yeah yeah so
it's yeah that is the actual plan I was
looking at it's just that landscape one
looks very very different
learning um
notation of strategic housing
normally policy is to secure pepper
potting or affordable housing throughout
the site but when they've been speaking
to rsls and RPS they've actually
preferred for a maintenance point of
view to have the units collected so that
when they're doing maintenance and
updates to the properties they're able
to
do them in a small
targeted burst in a small area rather
than across the site
thank you so
um in debate um
I don't like to see affordable housing
all in one line down the side of the um
A14
um beside a um a Bund
it's I just don't like to see it I think
it's um I think it's a bad design I can
understand
um
um why it's been done like that but it's
almost like the the affordable housing
and um charity housing is used as a
second sound buffer for the um the
self-built plots that are right down the
far end and everything
um
I saw the bites the Cherry but it is
like a late question it is a late
question because I got a bit confused
with my maps
um I'm thinking that I'd made a mistake
yeah
I'm gonna
um so so the plan that was just up there
was an old issue if that makes sense it
was subsequently
um when the roof plan was issued
um when the original submission went in
there was two separate plans so this is
the correct plan so there is a green
outline on this plan which you might not
be able to say particularly well
um effectively there's a cluster
um on the right hand side and they
obviously don't run in a back a bank
along the A14 so this is the correct
plan the plan that you saw was
superseded by this plan it was made
clear in the email but it's obviously
found its way in because it's got a
separate title instead of being called
site plan this is called the roof plan
um so it snuck its way in essentially
but the site plan
is this plan
[Music]
okay so on
I'll let Daniel
yep and then there's the two gray units
on the yeah there's those three there
then there's
um two below that directly below and
then there's another two directly below
that those that's really helpful because
that makes your query clearer doesn't it
that you're more satisfied with what
would be
apologies members that's my issue I
should have caught that whilst thank you
Sebastian you can switch your um your
microphone off please thank you
I must admit
yeah thank you is there any way you can
zoom in on that Daniel is there any way
we can zoom in no
yeah I can't clear my but I don't know
if we're streaming it okay fine
I
just wanted to reiterate the point that
uh yeah I wanted everyone to see it
around I can see that but the uh
looking back at gp1 and some of the
policies we've got I mean there's much
about this scheme to commend it the fact
that the affordables now are only
running at about 60 of that that
boundary with the road is is is is is is
a good one often you know I've often
asked the question why is it poor people
you know gravitate to want to live near
roads and railway lines but uh that
there is the layout is significantly
better
I do have an issue that I think is
solvable with some of these Heights uh
councilor Norris mentioned that
typically around here uh the houses are
two-story yet what we're approving here
are buildings that are in excess of
three-story in height
seven and a half meters is three stories
these are eight point three in the
majority these are very very large
structures when you look at them and and
some of that height could be capped off
because there's no living accommodation
in some of these very very large roofs
and I think that would then be more
sympathetic to what its surrounding is
and all of our local plan policies says
that should be looked at it should be
consistent with the built form that
surrounds it and and I've been looking I
can't see anything that's around this
current site that's in excess of two
stories in height yet what we have here
as I've said is is there's quite a lot
that's in excess of three stories in
height
uh and
and we know that modern buildings you
know have modern requirements and we get
that and we need to move on we can't
stay in the past but equally I think
there's an element of we ought to make
sure that this is also future-proofed
this isn't in the middle of a very
sustainable location yes it has planning
permission but there is no bus service
here you know it is a substantial walk
to a to a train station and to the
nearest shop Etc you know it's it's it's
not in an urban setting by any
structured imagination
uh which means the sustainability is
going to be key and I go back to those
designs of future proofing them there
there should have been a look at
the safe facing elevation rooms and
whether they are it can be solid in the
future and to have so many of them where
that is ruled out by approving the
current design is is a concern uh yes I
agree yeah the designs are quite
sustainable
to date as of today but we really need
to be serious about future proofing
these uh and we've seen a huge leap in
energy costs so energy cost is is also
in the eye of the buyer and the buyers
will be asking where can I put my solar
panels on these new homes and to quite a
lot of them they're going to be
seriously limited so I think that would
now is this or is all of this in my
items bad enough as it were to refuse
possibly not but I I think at present
times I would have quite liked those
Heights to be looked at and and the
making of more rooms to be able to be
solid to be something should be looked
at before I would say yes so if I had
my own personal opinion I would defer
this application for them to go and look
at whether that can be because I think
it can be easily improved and should be
improved thank you chair
thank you anyone else wish to speak
please
cancel the war boys thank you
yes thank you chair I think I'm falling
off the councilor Stringer in a way I
think
uh
it is better layout for the affordable
housing I'm still concerned that all the
affordable housing social units in one
one area
I'd like to see more integration
there's the orientation of the rooftops
and the height uh We've mentioned
um
measures for sort of
water usage I think I'd like to see some
uh comments regarding rainwater
harvesting and possible recycling of
brown water
uh we are as an area we are going into a
sort of a water shortage area I think so
these measures need to be considered
um the world members comments about over
development of the site and the visual
impact of these four or five bedroom
houses out of character this site in
particular the heights which is going to
really
uh be a dramatic impact
um and there's the the effect on local
facilities and the impact on the highway
I mean in this particular area that the
driving through it the roads are
are quite reasonable but they flow into
um
Mill
is it Mill Lane which flows into gate
across Gateway 14 the route into
need a market from this site is really
compromised if you go the other way onto
the
a140 going through Crete and Saint Mary
again it's got passages of quite
restrictive roadways so that there are
concerns regarding that
um there is a principle for development
but I think
uh
could look at the design of the site
and make it as even more sustainable
than it than it is I don't think we've
really sort of stretched that as far as
it would go so I'm not I'm not
completely convinced by the application
to approve it at this moment
thank you for that anyone else wish to
speak
to speak just on the orientation of the
houses it's very difficult to um get a
plan that works with all the houses with
with the reforientations around there
and I just don't know if it's possible
to get
that many houses on there that aren't
looking in each other's windows and
overlooking each other with all the
roofs
um pointing South but I can understand
um why that's been fed what does
what does worry me a little bit is down
the bottom the south side of it you've
got those trees
um if we could could we have the um
you've got these um trees right down the
south side which will
which will um overshadow on a lot of
these Gardens
um as they get bigger and bigger
um and I don't want trees to be cut down
to give light or um you know be able to
move into a house with a nice sapling
outside and the you know be shaded later
on and I do wonder if there's a way we
could still have the benefit of having
those trees on site but um maybe um
move them a bit further away or
elsewhere on the site to them to give
those houses the um
sunlight coming in
or
make make sure that the species
are ones that will stay at a certain
height that don't get above sort of six
meters or something like that and I
don't know if that's possible but um
obviously the principle of development
has been established
this um
this design I think yeah it it does work
um the affordable housing spread out
a lot more than it was originally which
is is nice to see
um I don't know if there's still
self-build plots on there now because I
haven't quite um got to grips with the
new map
have we um
still got those until they ask the app
if you'd like to nod your head um
there's not they've gone okay
but yeah I don't know I can understand
um what councilors are saying about
looking into the design a bit more but
to be honest I think this is pretty much
there as a design now that we've got
that outline permission but um I'll um
I'll leave it there thank you
it's a very very good point to be raised
in this debate but like we said the
outline permission has been previously
granted on this application I do
particularly like the layout but like I
said I do accept the points made by
cancer Stringer about the very steep
ruse on some of these properties but
overall uh personally I would actually
move that we approve this application
very much do I have a secondary at all
councilor Castle I'm happy to
um do you um second that um I'd like the
conditions on the flooding to be met but
they will be met because it's I you know
that's that's why I understand that
officers are looking to do
um
I don't know if we want to have the
driveways permeable whether that's
suitable for this site
or not but um
they are they are okay so yeah thank you
so um yeah I'm happy to Second thank you
yeah thank you chair um
struggling a little bit with this one I
have to say
um simply because I understand hopefully
that the principle of development is
established we're going to have some
houses here and then what we're dealing
with really is the kind of detail and
the design
and I um it doesn't feel to me like
we've got here is close enough to what
we aspire to as a council and to what
the mppf aspires to in terms of a good
design
paragraph one three four of the mppf
development that is not well designed
should be refused especially where it
fails to reflect local design policies
and I'm not sure that this does
you know get close enough in terms of
reflecting the local vernacular that's
around that area which is Bungalows and
Chalet bungalows
much much steeper and taller than this
and it's obviously in the location
that's going to be seen very very
clearly even with the three meter Bund I
mean every vehicle that goes along the
A14 is going to see the height of these
dwellings
and it's going to look different
so as far as it stands at the moment I
don't think I can support this on the
basis of the design and not fitting with
policy h15
thank you for that Council Stringer yeah
I'd Echo some of that I think I possibly
I wasn't looking to the developer tear
up everything they've done and and and
start again what I was suggesting was a
a little rethink could have got us a lot
closer to something that is genuinely
going to be deliverable
we have a number of sites at the moment
already in construction in Suffolk there
are I think there are
200 already under construction in bacter
at the moment only two of them sold
and and one of the requirements of the
people wanting to buy them that they're
asking about where can I put solar
panels in because I want my energy bill
to be lower quite rightly so so we've
already seen one major developer there
changed from the heating system to make
it more sustainable so they can actually
sell some of these so arguing arguing
that there should be the ability to put
solar panels on in the future is not
trying to get to some sort of above regs
at the moment he's actually trying to
make sure they'll be able to be sold
they're deliverable and actually if you
the biggest problem with the design we
have at the moment for this is is where
the dormal windows are so if some of the
dormal windows were put on the other
side of the house you'd then get a
perfect safe facing slope for the solar
grounds we've got on so we're not
talking about tearing the whole plan up
and starting again it's the same with
the 8.3 meter elevation there is there
is no livable space at 7.5 meter yeah
below five meters I don't think in these
dwellings so know the the roofs could be
as it were capped off to stop that bulk
I mean 8.3 meters next door to a chalet
bungalow
frankly is going to look there's going
to be gasps it is a very very large
structure and I know from similar
structures we've now had built locally
when they hit more than seven and a half
meters they start looking incredibly
bulky you then start putting them in a
in a landscape that's surrounded by what
is mostly 60s and little Victorian
cottages and 60s Chalet bungalows
it's going to look out of place if we're
not careful so that's why we would I was
suggesting we could defer this for them
to go and see if we can look really look
at that design thank you Jim
I have a proposal and a second uh if
anyone else wishes to speak in which
case can we go to the vote please
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
foreign
thank you chair that is four votes for
and free against those courage
thank you very much um do we have any
site visits planned
none receiver thank you
um so in which case I formally closed
the meeting but can I just ask members
and officers to stay behind and thank
you very much
um Mr blemings thank you if you'd like
to leave